good morning John I am currently in
Haiti no I'm in my office but by the
time you see this I will be in Haiti so
I'm pre recording this video because I'm
not gonna have internet connection while
I'm in Haiti and people haven't asked me
to make a video about the science of
zombies so I thought that I would get
that out of the way right now there is
no science of zombies there has never
been nor will there ever be an undead
creature life is an extraordinarily
complicated balance of inputs and
outputs and temperatures and reactants
and wastes and fuels and if any of that
stuff breaks down none of it works
homeostasis look it up and then stop
worrying about zombies but this does
lead me to an interesting thought how in
fiction are supernatural beings created
and what does that say with you who
write those stories and the people who
are interested in those stories so
zombies for example generally created by
disease just like rabies you get bit you
get the disease you get sick you go
crazy then you die and then you undying
then you yourself become a vector for
the disease there are other examples of
disease based conversion from natural to
supernatural werewolves being another
one like zombies but also vampires now
that pirates get their power from a
disease but it seems very different from
zombies and it is in fact quite
different from zombies because zombies
are a disease based in violence whereas
vampires are a disease based in romance
sexytime which kind of makes sense why
women are more interested in the vampire
stuff and the men are more interested in
the zombie stuff because it's like
action movies versus chick flicks except
the supernatural monsters version of
that argument no this is pretty
unsurprising because sex and disease and
violence probably some of the very most
important forces in the lives of early
humans but newer myths created by
fiction writers and a lot of comic
writers provide these same kind of
insight superheroes nowadays don't so
much get their power from disease and
sex and violence superheroes which began
to be created in the 1930s or so get
their power from things that we believed
or believed hold great power spider-man
is a great example because once upon a
time he got his powers from being bitten
by a radioactive spider and that was
back when radioactivity and atomic power
held all this promise of potential like
cheap energy for everyone and also the
potential for the destruction of the
entire world but that one spider-man got
revamped for the next generation they
cut out the radioactivity because that
wasn't
sex anymore and instead they put in a
genetically modified spider and thus we
can say about ourselves as consumers of
content that the aura of mystery and
power and fear that once surrounded
radioactivity and atomic energy now has
moved over into genetically modified
stuff all these things that within our
culture hold a great deal of power and
mystique like money and technical
expertise in the government as a hero
and the government as a villain atomic
power outerspace the internet particle
physics our genes our brains our
obsession with all these things have
grown and waned over the years as has
their use in the creation of superheroes
and of course John and your zombie
apocalypse novella you did this very
thing you took a source of power and
fear and mystery for Humanity the
genetic engineering of crop and you
mixed it with the existing zombie myth
to get zombies who died and then like to
plant lots of corn you fell directly
into the archetype like everybody else
of course everyone falls in the
archetype that's what archetypes are for
so I'm always keeping my eye out for new
and unique ways that superheroes are
being created because I think it's a
really clear indicator of what we're
becoming obsessed with and what we're
becoming afraid of for example there's a
new movie coming out and which an
out-of-work writer takes this pill and
he becomes a super genius and of course
this reflects our fear and fascination
about what is going on with brain
chemistry and pharmaceuticals
superheroes and other supernatural
beings are of course fictional and they
seem like they're just there for fun but
they do provide us I think with a great
opportunity to analyze ourselves and
what we're becoming obsessed with and
what we're becoming afraid of
interestingly those two things often the
same thing so it's nice to see that this
entire shelf of science fiction here in
fact allows me to learn more about us as
humans John I'll see you on Monday